hey dr. Berg here in this video we're
going to talk about blood sugars okay
very very very important yet very
misunderstood if you have diabetes if
you have hypoglycemia which is low blood
sugar if you're concerned about
preventing those you want to watch this
video now here's how it works the law of
the body is that no matter what the body
must maintain a certain level of sugar
in the blood okay so the blood sugar
level will call it glucose level should
always be right around 100 now if you
want to know the unit's I think it's
milligrams per deciliter but don't worry
about that but there's blood testing
units that you can test your blood and
it should be right here now it does
range between 80 and 110 but if that
blood sugar goes too high okay that's
called hyper
glycemia that means that's diabetes okay
if the blood sugar is too low that is
called hypoglycemia okay so the goal for
the body is to maintain blood sugar of
100 so it'll do everything it'll tear
the body apart it'll turn it'll break
down your muscle protein with one goal
is to maintain normal blood sugar so
everything that almost everything you
eat eventually breaks down into glucose
or sugar okay even foods that are not
sugar even protein and fat will break
down and then you're going to build it
the body will build it back up into
sugar so sugar is used for fuel and
nourishment to the cells so the way it
works is this you have this huge organ
here called the liver the liver is on
the right side of your body it's about 3
and 1/2 pounds the size of a football
and then we have this tiny organ right
here which is called the pancreas and
that's right right here on the right
below the left ribcage now these two
organs
reciprocate and what I mean by that is
they they have a mutual relationship
they coordinate they kind of control the
blood Sugar's okay but the liver is the
most ignored piece of the puzzle in
diabetes which we'll get into simply
because here's how it works the liver
controls blood sugar when you're not
eating and the pancreas controls blood
sugars when you eat all right and they
go back and forth and back and forth so
what the pancreas does is it makes a
hormone
it's called insulin and it basically
what it does is it gets the sugar out of
the blood okay so it takes it out it
reduces blood sugar okay so there's
hormones that lower that sugar all right
that's when you're eating because you
just ate and you're flooding the blood
with sugar even if you don't eat sugar
because everything turns out into sugar
eventually now when you're not eating we
need to kind of raise the sugar so your
liver will put sugar in to the blood
okay so it goes in alright so and it
does it through a hormone that's very
similar to insulin but it does the
opposite and they call that insulin like
growth factor
so it's an instant like one but IGF it
don't even worry about that right now
just realize there's the hormone that
basically and where it gets the sugar is
it gets the sugar from two sources one
is the muscle and the liver okay and
that that's basically stored sugar okay
so in other words your body has stored
sugar and the word for that is glycogen
that's basically a bunch of sugars
that's stored in the body so you can use
it
okay and it also gets it from fat
alright so those are the two sources
that you're tapping into so obviously
that's the goal is to be able to lose
fat or tap into fat but that's the
purpose of fat is to act as a storage so
you can use it when you're not eating
okay or starving or exercising or
fasting those things so the lever
basically takes that fat and it converts
it into sugar and it puts all this sugar
back in the blood to keep that 100 but
first it goes after the store sugar so
this is number one and this is number
two so in the presence of any stored
sugar or any sugar at all this fat will
not be used at all the body does not
like to burn fat in normal situations
unless there's no sugar there okay so
the way it works simply is the pancreas
regulate sugar it put pulled sugar out
when you're eating and then when you're
not eating the liver starts kicking in
there and puts the sugar back in and
starts to take this storage and start to
put it back in the blood to maintain a
sugar at 100 now let's talk about
briefly what happens when that sugar
gets pulled out of the blood when
insulin goes up
okay so there's three situations that
occurred number one that energy of that
sugar could be used as energy immediate
energy let's say you're exercising so
you're going to be using up your energy
or doing a marathon the person's eating
sugar and it's kind of burning up or
number two it's being stored as sugar on
that stored sugar in your liver and in
the muscles so we want that to happen
because if it's stored then it's not
converted to fat okay so I'd rather have
stored sugar than fat right because
stored sugar is just gonna use for
energy but we don't want too much so
this certain amount of sugar that's
stored in the body but in order to store
this sugar right here what happens is
that you need potassium alright
without potassium you can't store sugar
so for every sugar a little molecule you
need one potassium molecule like that so
potassium is like the glue to hold
together so with low potassium levels
the person will start craving sugar why
because they can't store sugar so they
crave sugar why because the sugars are
going down and the body's telling you
give me that sugar so the symptom of
cravings means your body has a low blood
sugar and it's really low potassium so
what does have what happens in people
crave sugar they go eat sugar right what
they should consume is potassium now the
problem that most people have is they
don't really know how much potassium
they need on a daily basis an average
body needs 4700 milligrams
that's a lot in fact one banana is 400
so you'd have to have 10 bananas that's
not going to work so we really need our
bodies need 7 cups minimum of vegetable
every single day now if you're doing one
cup or two cup it's not going to cut it
and if you're taking a pill it's like 40
milligrams you have to have like a
hundred of them so we want to do the
vegetable so you can do the kale shake
for breakfast as part of it and have
your eggs whatever and then for lunch
have this huge salad for dinner have
some more vegetable but we really want
to shoot for 7 cups and if you're at all
interested in managing or improving your
blood sugar issues this is a must
especially if you have diabetes okay so
we want to store sugar and then and also
if there's too much sugar to be pulling
out and that sugars not being used as
energy and you don't have potassium
guess what it goes right to fat so it's
being converted to fat so that is one
relationship between potassium and fat
if you don't consume enough vegetables
or potassium you tend to gain more fat
all right so that's just those are the
three things that occur with where the
sugar goes after you consume sugar and
the spike of the hormone insulin from
the pancreas now the next point has to
do with what is diabetes diabetes is a
condition where your body has no longer
been able to regulate the sugar in here
and it comes from consuming obviously
too much sugar that's the
common cause but here's the thing
diabetes type 2 is a less serious
diabetes type 1 is a more serious type
type of diabetes so type 2 is really a
problem with the liver because what
happens is the they take a drug called
glucophage or another name for metformin
and what all that does is it makes the
cells in the liver more receptive or
receiving more insulin so they work on
the receptors in the liver
ok receptors so they increase the
conductivity of insulin so each receptor
in the liver for insulin becomes
magnified and there's 200,000 receptors
for insulin for every liver cell that
you have so if you could imagine really
what diabetes type 2 is it's insulin
resistant resistive whatever you want to
call it so I guess the best analogy
let's say you had a bunch of
telemarketing people call your house
over and over and over every day for a
year you're not gonna pick up any more
okay you're not going to keep picking up
every time they call you're going to be
a bit resistive to that communication so
that's what diabetes type 2 is being
very resistant resistive to insulin and
then they take this drug called
glucophage which basically makes it more
it picks up the phone a lot more so then
now we can receive that insulin
communication and thus lowering the
blood sugar okay so diabetes medication
lowers the blood sugar so usually
because these diabetes it's a high sugar
state and the problem is that if you
ever have a low blood sugar and you take
these medications it's going to make it
worse because you're going to go even
lower so you don't want to take
medication if it's too low or normal
only when it's too high and the problem
when the blood sugar goes low many times
people are taking sugar pills which
basically make the problem worse because
now you're going to spike listen to hi
we're trying to avoid that situation
now type 1 diabetes is not a liver
problem it's a long-term chronic problem
of the pancreas and now the cells of the
pancreas that make insulin are exhausted
and they pretty much just stop working
so there boy therefore no insulin is
being produced
therefore the sugar goes higher and
higher and higher and higher and so then
now they need insulin injections to
lower the sugar and they have to keep
taking through the day they have time
release and all sorts of things so that
is the difference between these two type
2 is the liver type 1 is the pancreas
problem this is worse because now you
don't make any insulin type 2 you do
make insulin but it doesn't work on the
liver so that's the relationship between
the two and then the real underlying
cause our bodies are not designed to
consume a hundred and forty-nine pounds
of sugar per year our bodies are not
designed to consume as much sugars we're
eating I mean even baby food is loaded
with high fructose corn syrup you have
all this juice that the kids are fed and
what we consume the sodas and all that
we have way too much sugar and the cells
just are not designed to handle that and
it puts it right into an exhaustive
state so you have a lot of people going
around in diabetes but you need to
understand where the source is and so
the next part I'm going to show you some
even deeper information on that little
cycle okay now check this out we talked
about the liver and the pancreas and the
hormone in the liver and the hormone the
pancreas what's fascinating is that this
hormone is a hundred times bigger than
insulin as far as quantity of hormone in
other words the ratio is a hundred to
one as far as the work that's done the
majority of work of establishing blood
sugars is done by the liver yet very few
people emphasize the importance of the
liver and maintaining blood sugars it is
this one of the most important things to
keep healthy when you're trying to
establish blood
simply because the quantity of work that
the liver does is is a hundred times
bigger than insulin but everyone focuses
on insulin now why well how did that
happen why don't doctors know about this
why don't they make this more available
because if you and I found this I looked
at the units that they measure this
hormone in the liver
it's called IGF the units that it's are
different than insulin so in other words
they measure this hormone what's called
nano grams and this hormone by micro
moles so they're completely apples and
oranges so you cannot see this hundred
to one ratio in other words is kind of
like measuring metric versus inches or
what is it
Celsius versus Fahrenheit or gallons
versus ounces you have when you're
measuring two things that work together
they have to be the same units and if
they're not the same units you're going
to miss the fact that this liver is a
hundred times more important than the
pancreas everyone's know what's the
significant of that how can we use that
information well all we have to do
simply if we want to improve the
function of the blood sugars and correct
diabetic conditions is increase the
liver if you just increase the liver by
20% you basically you take 80% of the
stress away from the pancreas you you
create an tremendous relief from that
blood sugars and so the member of the
insulin cells that are actually
exhausted are overworking because all
the sugar coming in there so what we're
trying to do is reduce the stress on
that cell to salvage that so the
significance is all you have to do is
improve the liver by a little bit to
take a lot of pressure off this pancreas
here simply because this is where this
needs to do its lion's share and so that
leads to what most people have is liver
damage but it won't show up on a blood
test so later in life so when you damage
the liver by consuming too much alcohol
or too much cook foods or junk foods or
even not enough vegetables because the
the way to repair the liver is through
raw
and that is why I start everyone out on
the liver enhancement in my book chapter
10 because if you improve the liver
function you actually can help a lot of
different problems also age every decade
you get older and you reach the age of
50 you lower this hormone called growth
hormone now some of you have heard that
the relationship between growth hormone
and anti-aging
well growth hormone is a major trigger
for the liver to release this hormone
right here that regulates blood sugars
so really I GF insulin-like growth
factor is an extension of growth hormone
they're both almost identical and
function so growth hormone does a lot
for regulating blood sugars so we want
to keep this high and so let's say
you're not eating a lot of sugar well it
could be that you're just getting older
to the fact that liver is not receiving
that growth hormone as much so there are
things you can do to improve it but the
fact that is the growth room when that
goes down you have to be even better on
your diet because you don't have the
full capacity of that regulation of that
liver function see growth hormone does
three things it burns fat because it
really mobilizes fat for the blood
sugars it also helps you it's anti-aging
and it it's it protects your proteins so
it's called a protein spare hormone and
what that means is that it prevents your
protein from turning breaking down into
sugar and use for fuel okay so it
protects your protein what protein
collagen so you you avoid getting this
loose skin sagging belly all that and
also it protects your cartilage in
collagen in your knees and your
shoulders and these other joints so it's
a very important thing in protecting
muscle protein breakdown that's
occurring from the cortisol from the
stress remember that cortisol hormone
which is very destructive on your cells
when you go through a lot of stress that
will break down your muscle protein
especially in your thigh muscle in your
legs that's why you can't get your thigh
muscles toned because you have too much
of this darn destructive cortisol and
not
for that so we're trying to reverse this
process so how do we do it
number one intense exercise is very good
but that would be interval training very
important to keep growth rolling up and
I'm talking like short little tiny
workouts maybe 30 seconds resting for
three minutes back and forth every other
day versus the treadmill that will
actually enhance growth hormone unless
you're really really stressed and you're
not sleeping you're gonna have to walk
but eventually want to work up to
interval training okay and then number
two sleeping you need to sleep seven
eight hours to keep this growth roaming
really high and then the next thing is
you need to get your liver healthy you
need to do the liver enhancement you
need to really protect your liver and
prove it and so what are the foods that
will improve the liver
my favorite is you guessed it kale
everything comes back to that kale
doesn't it we've talked about that in
every single video and kale is one of
the super foods to heal and protect your
liver because the liver loves the bitter
vegetables and it's low sugar and it's
is a lot of properties to restore liver
function and when you have that Cal
shake in the morning the the liver will
improve and you'll get a lot of
potassium and you'll get more growth
hormone and you get less insulin and
you'll crave less and you'll be able to
maintain your age better and prevent the
protein breakdown and I've had lots of
people improve their blood sugars by
taking kale so I hope this video helped
you understand some of the basics of
blood sugars and apply this information
and I'll see you in the next video